so what's your name Michael Michael
Jackson
really yeah yeah
Michael uh where'd you grow up where are
you from originally
um right here downtown originally um
since 1970 yeah you're born downtown no
I was born in Tijuana Mexico but uh my
mother was already married here in
America with my dad who was from the
Navy she went to visit my aunt and I was
born there in Tijuana oh I see she was
already living here you were raised down
here since birth I've been here since
birth yeah so tell me about growing up
on Skid Row wow well it's been a
Journey an adventure it's like a scary
Las Vegas you know I gotta say I got the
dangerous Tijuana mixed with a uh
dangerous Las Vegas I gotta say uh and
and it's pretty mild today because uh uh
shortly back in the day
new people couldn't just stand at the
corner 15 minutes they'd be asked to
keep it moving or they would be
unconscious and Rob it was that bad that
bad I I would be standing right there
for some reason I've never been bothered
uh they've accepted me but I've I've
witnessed the harshest the most ruthless
um and uh
just I wouldn't recommend it but but
then again there's something that draws
you to it it's addicting you know they
say uh many come to LA to find their
Hollywood and many get lost in their
Hollywood here same with Skid Row many
people come
and and don't make it out or leave with
nothing and and worse than they ever you
know uh you gotta have to be very very
strong-minded because uh
it's a world of sharks yeah you live
here currently yeah yeah so you you
decide you never decided to leave I I
left once or twice for a short time but
you know it's so much that's here for
example from there's a lot of blessings
but also there's the meals out here and
then the small resources that just help
you through a day you know uh nothing
you can count on but it does help here
so you get addicted to just being near
your Safe Haven even though it's
dangerous it's kind of a safe haven too
how did you grow up I mean you uh well
these streets are meant for kids yeah
well you know at the time when I was a a
kid my parents had jobs on opposite
sides of town uh one on second in Los
Angeles 199th in Maine
so as a kid they would babysit me and I
would have to run across town and I
wasn't supposed to go through Skid Row
or anything but I got to be honest as a
horny little kid I will go through where
I'm not supposed to and you know they
used to have uh back in the day the
hookers were working out of the adult
theaters that were on Main and you could
see that today on Beretta and Starsky
and Hutch where they chased the criminal
and they go to the theater and well as a
kid I was supposed to go through
Broadway but the posters and the adult
theater and then The Pimps outside and
The Cadillacs was so interesting that I
would always go where I wasn't supposed
to and it became addicting that I I met
a lot of people as a kid I was too young
to know
so much I gotta say and I think that's
what made me fortunate to be able to sit
everywhere comfortably because I don't
know very many people who can just walk
in all corners of of skid row safely you
know uh it became comfortable for you it
became comfortable for me a lot of
people were kind I know some people were
uh where I shouldn't go where I
shouldn't be but for some reason you
just happen to be at the wrong place at
the right time and and I've known since
a kid
three monkeys I see nothing I hear
nothing I say nothing and it's a really
really a strong Rule and I know Matt
since the kid so I I guess um
through all the hard things I saw I I
got by it just by minding my business
it's hard my brothers say hardest thing
in life is for one to mind one's
business you know and so I've learned to
live that way and it's really blessing
but what are some of the craziest things
you've seen down here I've seen from um
from back when I was young do you
remember the frontier hotel right yeah
yeah yeah the frontier I I remember from
back when I was young
as far as today back from the 90s and
80s uh on the first when they used to
give out food stamps paper uh not a card
guaranteed a body would be flying out
the window they knock on your door
Rampage uh just uh run in your room grab
your stuff throw you out the window and
my dad used to tell me about it and I I
I didn't realize how real it was as I
was growing up and witnessed I gotta say
since a kid I probably witnessed
15 corpse flying out a window and out of
the 15 out of which buildings well one
of them was uh The Standard Hotel
the Alexandra
uh the Roslyn uh which used to be the
frontier
was it the new Roslyn is the old
Frontier oh okay I didn't know that part
yeah I I I and uh and I remember the
frontier and uh uh uh the Rosalind
Warehouse uh the standard even second in
fig it's called the
um they're called The Promenade Powers I
think permanent Towers
uh the fifo I didn't witness it but I
was in the environment at that time you
know they're all in the same yeah five
block area yeah they are they are the
one the one of the most recent one was
the standard uh it was a rainy day after
the club three in the morning and the
bar I just hear the thumb you could hear
the Splat of the blood hitting the wall
that's actually what I heard after the
thump I could hear that like a hose
going
and that's when I look oh my God and
that dude was on his neck his neck was
totally shifted and um
there was one here at uh Second and fig
the Promenade Towers uh we were
underneath the liquor store
and we heard a thump at 10 p.m 10 p.m it
was raining and next you know the
water's turning red and we didn't think
anything of it we were joking it looks
like blood and it was until we hear the
sound of the paramedics maybe we
realized that a lady jumped from the top
floor and hit the uh the the solid Eve
over there and splatter it it was no the
patio upstairs landed in a woman's patio
and the blood was twinkling down in
front of the store and we were just
sitting there like wow wow
yeah those are mild compared to some of
the shootings and deaths you know
because uh I've been two feet from
shootings
and luckily I just put my hands on my
face and said hey I know I don't know
anything man and I started walking away
hoping that they don't shoot me but I
just
put my eyes in my face walked away and
uh uh
yeah those are scary things yeah
um
I I understand people get uh postpartum
depression you know from like these
things are enough to do PTSD PTSD enough
for someone to develop that just from
the dramatic thing they witnessed and uh
but I guess I'm so used to it since a
kid like I've seen
uh here's one
uh I was about 12 years old and I
witnessed I'm gonna get robbed so hard
with a pipe on Main Street Main and
Third Street at the Corner Bar
35 years 40 years later I met a famima a
little restaurant kind of Starbucks
thing they went out of business but it
was kind of like a Starbucks
and I meet this man that looks so
familiar to me and he's telling me a
story oh I don't mind it's not dangerous
for me I've been robbed before and you
know I'm I'm Irish I can hold my own
and I turned out to be the guy who was
Rob when I was a kid
I told him the story he told me the
story we confirmed and it was amazing
and they still had the scar on his
Cranium from from the big hit with a
pipe and uh just witnessed so much uh
robberies
uh uh I remember I knew this person
miscellaneous
they were telling a story about the
tunnels under downtown there's many
tunnels so this guy to confirm it went
and they realized it leads underneath
the electronic shop on Spring which no
longer exists they closed that shop it's
a restaurant now so um
they get caught he gets deported he
comes back gets redeported and uh that
was an interesting story that we were
just reminiscing about the tunnels
underneath downtown and the guy took
advantage went and he grabbed some TVs
but they caught him and he's currently
in El Salvador deported and poor guy but
I uh just so many ruthless stories uh
lots of overdoses in my face a friend of
mine just died at the YMCA
I was begging him to let me be there
while he uses
because I could resuscitate him but he
just said I don't deserve to see it no
my you know these are you don't do this
you know I'm like come on I begged him
and uh the next morning
his brother's calling me screaming my
brother's at the YMCA dead and then that
one I still feel that one because me and
the guy was young and and we used to sit
for hours every night before we each
went our own way
I would give him a little food or he'll
give me a little pot I'll give him a
dollar or two he'll give me you know a
beer whatever we had we would share it
and when he died at that one affected me
out of all the deaths I've ever seen
because I shared time with this kid you
know and here's a terrible thing about
downtown
totally off subject that I witnessed
it's a psychotic topic that people can't
comprehend but I witness I believe about
five percent of every building here
of those people are involved in gang
stalking because there's been uh people
on drugs who I I'm across the street I'm
sitting at the Grand Park where the
courthouse is and this one particular
guy who just died I'm speaking of
I see him at the corner paranoid
screaming at people but then again I
seen cars circling them and parking and
pointing the lights at them and people
walking dogs running like
the idea of that is for him to Outburst
he gets arrested and he got him the area
they got him out of the area or he goes
crazy and kills himself and or
um uh he gets arrested for whatever
reason and I've seen this occur with
many people
and since they're on drugs who's going
to believe them
but I first hand in the guy who wasn't
on drugs observing from across street
and that's a terrible thing you know and
and uh so gang stalking is what it's
where uh there's groups that get
together sometimes through email through
organizations and and they maybe want
you out of the area so they'll tend to
there's tactics like
um
you'll tend to notice where we sit a car
will park and the angle they have the
high beams pointing at you at all time
uh it could be a lady all of a sudden
standing next to you with a dog and
another guy's on right a foot away
during covet even when you're supposed
to maintain distance and they're just
standing there with the lead hopefully
hoping you get irritated and move on or
um The Whisper things and you would
never guess they're saying it because
they don't know you you don't know them
it's totally different culture it could
be a Caucasian man it could be an Asian
man but uh
to the point where
you're the only one hearing it because
they don't realize they're doing it to
you and I'm saying this because I
witnessed this I would tell my friend
who died be strong I want you to know
something they are messing with you they
are following you
and realize it don't react be strong
don't react but it it got to him he was
at the point where he was already
out bursting [__] you lady or you know I
and and people were beating him up
constantly and I saw it's for real and
that's one thing I like to bring up that
it's a terrible thing because in Vegas
when that thing happened in Vegas
I believe I would have saved 95 of the
people the other five percent I say I'm
sorry you're probably statistically
involved in that and you probably
deserve this you know they're they're
hidden Killers hidden Killers my friend
could have jumped off the bridge
could have you know done something crazy
based on these people doing that to him
and nobody will believe him because he's
on drugs and that's very sad and I'm
here to say it's for real so uh best
thing to do is when you come to downtown
is keep your nose clean and then and
don't irritate anyone because uh it's
kind of a United Community the whole Los
Angeles you know and drugs have not been
a part of your life
yeah I gotta say on and off I'm not
gonna lie uh I'm a guy that sits on
everybody's table and uh whatever so I'm
a guy that
never has to pay you know how hard it is
for someone like me to fight to not
receive to not use because when you have
a big family
you don't charge your family
it's all love it's gift hey man you okay
here you go hey are you okay Manny well
you know and I could use some pot well
she'll hand it to me and hey man you'll
have me doping and with no request with
with no I'm not even seeking it on a
daily I can walk out of here and have a
handful of something and it's a real big
challenge to to not indulge so try and
imagine the tourist or the new person
where there's so many salesmen just
throwing it at you throwing it at you
throwing it at you it's a matter of time
before
your your Cravings start to uh have a
taste buds for it and you're involved in
the life I've been strong so I'm
grateful but I have dabbled throughout
my weary walk and uh uh I gotta say that
I'm one that if I make a left I realize
it's time to go back on the main Highway
you know a figure of speech because
um I have many friends my friends from
Ohio I have a friend from Chicago who
are still here and they're not doing as
well downtown's eating them up alive
but uh yeah I dabbled I gotta say I've
dabbled in a little bit of everything uh
uh no fentanyl no heroin but I did you
know heavy duty on the map for a minute
and uh and uh you know PCP uh you know
whatever it I don't even base it on me
wanting it it's based on the environment
this guy throws it out there everyone's
having fun and I you know okay schedule
is just a party it's just a part of me
yeah and uh no but it's a party it's it
it can be yeah it can be I think it can
be violent as can be but but for most
people it's just a never-ending party
the enticing of women is an incredible
thing
you know
first give them everything they want hey
girl you need help here and they buy him
a soda and hey you could stay here by
their technique yeah don't worry the
girl feels comfortable so she starts
playing songs by night time he's kind of
playing constantly pulling out the stuff
lights it up for her doesn't really want
to but then she takes a hit after that
first hit
they just everyone's encouraging here
take another thing by morning she's a
zombie
after a couple of days with her in the
tent one maybe two three guys
they don't want her anymore they throw
her out and she walks about crazy and
you know what one thing that they after
that process where they throw out of the
tent and she moved on she'll walk around
I'm sorry she'll walk around with a
t-shirt
as as a uh address yeah you see that all
the time yeah the T-shirt will be the
dress they leave with no shoes nothing
and it's a terrible thing uh I've seen
deterioration of of the best
become the worst and but I've seen many
persevere too and uh uh it's dangerous
it was so dangerous that
that
if it wasn't
a robbery it was just somebody getting
punched out or somebody overdosing
um there used to be a lot of beautiful
women in this kid around all high as
hell oh I didn't know but I gotta say
wow I can't believe she's here oh my God
she's new and a couple weeks later it
was like damn
damn that's my only expression it's like
what happened and uh how many years
you've been here since 1970. but how old
are you now I'm 52. you're 52. yeah so I
was a schedule changed over the years uh
today it's mild it's very mild there's a
lot of there's some people dying every
day yeah murders and overdose but uh but
the drugs are heavy duty always you know
something that yeah there's some things
you won't change you'll never change the
cartels you know because then there's
there'll be another to take over they'll
never change certain things and one
thing about downtown is they say is that
um
panhandling is from out of town
you got people from I'm from Ohio I'm
from Idaho and they Panhandle in
downtown you hustle
everybody has a hustle because even the
ogs or the even the women will tell you
after too much leaning on them but can I
get some credit or can I have a
certainly you need to get a Hustle
so people it's kind of motivating that
you get up and find something you know
uh back in the day I used to pick up
these phone wires on a daily
and daily and every day I'd go to the
library I sell about good 14 worth of
wires I picked up daily and I stayed a
good hour over there and someone always
comes on hey do you have a USB hey do
you have a charger so uh once it was um
sunflower seeds they gave them out at
the mission I got 12 bags two for a
dollar you know what I mean and so
without a hassle there's no drug
there's no T-shirt you might want to buy
there's no you know so everyone has to
have a hustle it's so important for
downtown panhandling is from out of town
did you say it in the tent before huh
have you stayed in the tent before
I used to always do boxes you know a
long time ago there were no tests yeah
it was all boxes and Tents are actually
new maybe 50 20 years 20 years I think I
think I started coming down here 13
years ago
they would pop up at night sometimes but
during the day you'd not see about 2012
10 started coming out you know yeah I
came down and there was a problem with
that you know people the big problem
with that they didn't allow it and they
didn't like it and you got to tear it
down but everyone persevered they made
the new rule that okay but you got to
tear down at six but I always use boxes
because for one I was never one to um
want to stay in the tent throughout the
day or leave property and it's stolen so
I would make uh I would always get three
boxes and make a pill the center one
opens like a space shuttle and it gets
so warm that I would literally sleep
with shorts and a t-shirt even on rainy
days you know uh another one you know
the uh the uh detour signs they have a
light they flash if you open three of
them in open that's a that's a tent in
itself
so I would always get those and put them
in the same area I'll I'll pile three
and then three on the other side of town
so that whenever I go the city never
Picks Them Up I can use the utilize
those for emergency shelter you know I
would just put cardboard on the two
walls open three up and I yeah schedule
is unique because the uh the police will
roll by and just they'll see people
doing everything yeah illegal it's so
casual it's so casual and then uh that's
the thing but then again The Outsider
stands out
because there's a casual way how
everyone does everything and and then
and The Outsider comes in these loudy
he's running across the street he's
waving you down from a distance those
are many things you don't do you know
and so uh it takes time I see many
tourists and new people get beat up a
few times before they become this hip
guy you know it seven years later they
know all the ropes they're telling other
people yeah you gotta because you got to
keep it down but I remember when they
came in and they had to get a couple of
fatties before before they develop that
character of you never had the desire to
leave Skid Row or do something different
um
you know what I I've been through some
heart a lot of Misfortune um when I was
working in downtown I uh scorpion landed
on my face with my feet being behind my
neck so surgery kept me from working
where am I gonna go you know the
resources are here I could snap in
downtown no when you that's when you
fall and land on your face and your feet
go behind you oh I see yeah so I have uh
10 pins in my neck right now oh Jesus
yeah that's recent from my last job but
uh just many misfortunes uh um here's
another one uh while I was working from
the street my company was really
defrauded me with insurance so bad that
that I couldn't afford my rent and I
said you know what I'm going back on the
street I preferred having a big plate
over I said you know what forget this
apartment I really love to eat I want a
big plate and I turned in my I went out
to Rosman I turned it in just because I
wanted a bigger plate
so Some people prefer living on the
streets sometimes you have to see that's
the thing uh
I don't think they feel comfortable with
a an apartment
some people are so accustomed to it it's
like
I stood at a place once where they were
helping for about three months and they
were already preparing me to move me
here and move there I said hey I feel
like Tarzan when they gave him a shirt
what did he do he went right back to the
Jungle you got to give people time to
domesticate again you know and realize
oh I got to be in at 10. well you know
what uh uh just to realize you're inside
an environment to this day
sometimes I'll visit a relative because
I have relatives one or two not very
many but and I can't be in the car long
I need the window down I'll be in their
house and say you can spend the night
I'll say no you know what I need the air
I can't even stain the closed
environment there I'm not claustrophobic
but when everyone goes to sleep in the
house
I don't care if it's a five bedroom I
could hear you breathing four bedrooms
away because you have to be so alert
being on the street you know the one eye
open thing that I've learned to always
hardly sleep and to always be slightly
awake and uh and to be always aware of
my environment that if I go to anybody's
home and I I don't stay I don't spend
the night anywhere because
I could hear the person breathing four
rooms away I could hear the person
approaching the porch on the door
in my book all that sounds like creeping
and when you're out there you got to be
safe and you just learn to you know I
could sleep next to a train and sleep
like a baby
but if somebody's tiptoeing near me I
will get up in a minute
it's an amazing creeping wakes me up
it's I I I can't express it
two kids uh I have two girls yeah yeah
that was another
thing is the at the time
I was working at Albertson in Highland
Park when they were on strike that was
20 years ago or something in that 15.
and so uh again I ended up in downtown
became a courier in downtown
and uh here I am that's how I scorpioned
uh when I was at Albertsons I was also
living on the street because of um a lot
of support and I rather give my girls
the money that I would stay outside at
the park
and then show up every day and walk them
to school and then pick them up let's go
bring back maybe stay for some homework
and I'd go off to our graveyard and the
next day I do it again and always
telling my girls Daddy has to go home
they never knew I was in the street I
said Daddy has to go home because he has
to go to work and I would just show up
the next morning to take him to school
taking the work yeah what is it that you
think it keeps most of these people down
here a lot of it I gotta say something
you don't want to get jobs they don't
want to get out yeah a lot of it I got
to say is uh dependency
a lot of it is dependency you know
here you know a lot of youngsters are on
the street because and they won't tell
the truth it's not even for drug habits
a lot of youngsters who are fighting for
SSI won't pay their parents a few
dollars after they get their job After
High School
they start buying their Jordans they
want the cameras they want to go tell
people rapper and stuff and this has
always gone on you know that the parents
get tired because
they're putting up the food in this case
just you know at least if you give your
mom 20 bucks simply
but they don't so they get thrown out a
lot of them do and then that's a big
problem that they won't admit that they
don't help their parents you know what I
mean so when they have to go on their
own they end up with the friends and
that they're there they end up here and
things only get worse
that's for the youngsters but then
there's the uh people who know here's
one a lot of people who slam burn their
Bridges where they're at in Ohio
the whole town then they go to Chicago
then they go to uh and they burn their
Bridges then they come to LA
and they do the same thing they'll hang
out and be your good friend and they'll
share drugs with you and just as as they
got so many loans and haven't been able
to pay back they'll get one more final
loan from a friend get some stash and
they end up in I went to Nebraska
you know and and they do that a lot of
people slam will just move on after they
burn their bridges burn their Bridges
and and then uh I catch up I'm really
sharp on the light you know that's why I
I tend to make friends to a point
and as soon as I can tell what your
flavor is I know how much of myself to
offer you know like how much confidence
how should we hang oh they say let's go
here I'll say oh you know what I'll just
meet you here when you get back I've
learned to because it's only going to
lead to
to
worse um
but uh uh
um drugs a big one and it's hard for you
to be clean and be surrounded by all
these people that are on drugs you know
it's a challenge for me I do pretty well
but I can imagine because like I said I
have a big family out there I could walk
in every corner and I know someone and
they gratuitously with with with it's
like love they give you it's like a uh
Comfort it's like how you doing you're
all right hey well here you go man and
be good you could either sell it to make
yourself a few dollars to eat you can
use it if that's what your flavor or you
could just uh barter and trade to get
some material things like uh I was
craving a speaker one day my friend gave
me some meth I wasn't craving meth a guy
wanted math I got my speaker you know so
sometimes it's a commodity
here's one an interesting one they got
me here here for several years
I used to make my money on barter and
trade not even drugs people would come
with seven iPhones I want 30 bucks a
piece and I'd go two blocks away and get
150 a piece you know so I'd give him his
30 a piece I made my week another guy
had speakers the guy a Japanese guy came
and he had a big bag of pot Maybe
a glad bag uh
15 gallon 20 20 gallon bag and he just
needed a bike so another friend had a
bike
how much you want for it I gave him the
ten dollars for the bike I gave the
Japanese guy the bike he gave me the
thousand dollar bag of kush you know and
I used to make my money just on barter
and trade until they started cleaning up
Skid Row
a lot of the dealers disappeared all the
women that were really rock skid roll a
lot of the hustle a lot of the danger
went away you know and so there's no
real big barter and trade for me anymore
it's really a struggle on a daily I'm
happy to make seven
on the day seven eleven bucks on the day
you know uh everybody knows me so I
might go get some food for this person I
might go and here's one they say why
don't you work for Uber because um
I only serve my community you know if
you're past Broadway or past Central
call Uber
because
what Uber doesn't do when my community
doesn't have money I will still go get
it for you that's the difference Uber
won't do that for you I only serve my
community and that's where I get a lot
of love because they remember hey man
you took care of me and and I feel
richer than hell you know just based on
the goodness from this dark environment
where I'm at yeah what would you say is
the most important lesson you've learned
in your life
to be honest
to keep it humble sincerely speaking to
not tell stories
to mind my business and and and
and and I know this sounds corny in
spite of walking weary and through the
dark side and maybe dabbling with a
little this and a little of that but
spiritually walking
sharing goodness sharing goodness
because
um
keep it humble so important when I was
with the most ruthless people just being
me not telling stories kept me alive
because I noticed when a new guy would
come in and eat yeah you know where I'm
in New York and I got my yeah in Chicago
we do it like this those guys would only
get beat up sooner or later because
I've learned to say less
and just be humble you know be courteous
be kind don't be a wuss
but just just don't talk too much when
you come to scarroia it's better to
listen uh hear the stories uh
uh but nobody likes a guy that comes
over here telling a lot of stories a lot
a lot of stories a lot of people come
and film uh and claim they came out of
skid row and then just for the glory of
my struggles and I've seen them get beat
up because they're they're that's
terrible to to fake the funk you know
but I gotta say staying humble uh and um
and don't tell stories and don't ever
Jack anyone don't borrow I learned never
to borrow
all these little things are so important
uh if I don't have it I don't want it
you know I I don't want it on credit
because
anytime somebody offers you something
hey you could take care of me later I
always tell them I'd rather keep the
friendship because once you owe that
friendship thing ended it goes to death
it goes to stitches it goes to four guys
just popped out of nowhere and just
cracked him and so uh
that's for real keep it humble keep it
real
don't tell stories and uh and and
another thing is I believe party hard
rock and roll hard but wake up the next
morning don't be a lazy ass laying
around it's good to wake up the next
morning because the early worm gives the
bird gets the barter gets the blessing
gets the trade you know found the coins
on the floor and I just all this became
me I'm totally downtown
to this day I don't think I want to go
anywhere else I never left L.A I don't
think I want to go anywhere else all
right Michael thank you so much I hope
it was youthful okay
thank you